[Music]
[Applause]
what's this what's this there candles
everywhere what's this there's bu air
what's this I can't believe my eyes are
being Dro in sodomized right over there
what's
this what's this what's this this all
sounds very wrong seven principles too
long what's this streets a line of
people doing goles what using Blackness
as a crutch am I going nuts what is this
what's
this when the children are done playing
they'll climb into their beds get fed a
load of crap from the stories they are
read they'll follow Kango I can't
believe the lies did they mention all
the girls he druged and beat and
T oh look the two people who celebrate
this day that clearly isn't fake they're
white cuz no one black really likes this
holler that you ask but theyd say what's
this oh look in here they've got a quan
tree a little derivative to me and hate
don't they realize it Ron Ard it even
called you is a psychotic is there
anyone who bought there a list I'm not
honest this looks like this looks
like he was a racist halfway T what's
this oh look the kids they made their
Quanza wish but someone stole their
Quanza gift I kid but can you please
just tell me why you praise a guy who
always tries to tell you this isn't your
homeand what's
this he'll say tell you of its value and
how support is strong but tell me can
you even name a single Quanza song you'd
say it's like black Christmas and I'd
say that's quite a leap why do people
sit here and listen to this
creep please just let me leave this
horrid place I'd like to go home right
away you know it's wrong to dat a
holiday on race and tell people to love
a place who've never been you'll never
go you know it's not your home I want
you go I want you go and it's just up
until I found what is
[Music]
this Quanza
Town remember none of this is possible
without you join the fight and sign up
for mug club today at lwith c.com
mugclub for $89 annually join the fight
at louth credit.com mugclub
[Music]
[Applause]
today
[Music]
what I
know
[Music]
ch
ah glad to be with you oh I don't no do
I have sound in my right ear doesn't
matter I went too far with a Q-tip again
oh no again wait these are the wrong
headphones that's why Yakuza what
happened you guys just switched my
headphones and didn't tell me those are
Gerald's why the son of a do you want
mine got your I'll get used to them are
they warm they're disgusting it's like
when you sit on one of those gross
toilet
seats we'll probably switch them during
one of the clips smell of el I'm just
not used to it any anyway a little
autistic with that waterb bur baby all
right
look I don't know what was going on I
just know something is different yeah I
looked at M I'm like these aren't my
headphones and he's like do you want
mine I'm like I don't think that's the
point those things you have to you have
to it's like a like a you have the
origami the thing but they fit right
they're a little bit thinner okay bring
up the rundown today we're going to be
talking about a lot I don't know if you
know this but the Senate is gay sodomy
is in heterosexual sex is out uh we're
going to discuss the flying V Vic
ramaswami VI versus van Jones whereas we
have also gone in versus van Jones and
if you watch the black and white and the
gray issues I talked about van Jones
being upset with Viv and not a single
black person knew who van Jones was so
there's that oh that's good and we'll
also be discussing a more macro topic
that the West is losing people are
talking about this great replacement
therapy which uh Theory not therapy I
mean it's therapy to some there's
hormone replacement therapy baby steps
there are a lot of replacement therapies
you know like replacing dads
so
wow the progressive left is effectively
Conquering the west from within you know
people have talked about Empires crumble
from within how does that happen what
are we witnessing there is a way to let
me ask you this a comment would help do
you think that you are fighting right
now when we say fight like hell to
preserve the United States of America to
preserve Western Civilization or at this
point are you fighting to um make sure
that you know who's going to be there to
rebuild
I think both are still you know still
optimistic uh both are potentially
possible but uh I think that it's time
to maybe accept that there there might
need to be some some rebuilding that
maybe that the uh the country that you
knew the civilization that you knew um
may not be around for your children and
it's going to have to be
rebuilt I don't know I go back and forth
on it so we'll talk about that and more
today and then I guess we have a oh
Photoshop or not for mug club members
yeah only all right Captain Morgan how
are you I'm doing well I can actually
actually these are fantastic you like
those headphones then we should just
both have those you get those headphones
no Merry Christmas no mer no no no I
insist they don't fit my ears well
really they
don't those antenni I know yeah well
they're you know bigger ears how are you
I'm fine aside from the can you can you
hear one doesn't work but the other one
works huh you only need one good ear I
guess you just turn it it's got to it's
got a thing you got to it's it's very
sensitive it's got a thing you have a
good weekend I did yeah yeah third chair
when you hear this you like it
you know who it is he's going to be at
the funny B Columbus Ohio December 22nd
and 23rd go and enjoy some Christmas K
Quanza Spirit uh Josh firin thank you
for your service how are you sir good
I'm spreading Quanza Joy this year
Stephen sorry no I don't know how I have
no idea I don't know how to you know
what I do want to switch our headphones
come on yeah hey take these ones I hate
I don't want you hate those ones yeah
sure tell you what you get the same
headphones I'm just kidding I just want
everyone Chinese fire drill here yeah
Chinese fire do we have the Chinese fire
drill
don't ruin my Christmas
tree where's this oh now I got to
reverse them cuz one's right one's left
okay hold on and now they're definitely
definitely going to be warm now by the
way one compliment from a lady that's
why this hair is absolutely insane it
looks great I can't hear you cuz my
headphones are on my
ears all right there we
go let's not clip that oh lack of change
clipping am I can I ask you something I
want to know if I'm a bad person or a
bad
I got my K I got an RC car really cool
monster truck RC car and then I just I I
was I could not you opened it yeah I
couldn't not play with it I Wasing I get
it I'm like lumpy RC cars my kid like
what is Dad doing outside mom's like
nothing go back ins When We Were Young
you had to have the crappy one that
could only turn left or you could get
one of the better ones but the battery
life lasted about 4 minutes yeah with no
wheel or no steering capabilities yeah
yeah yeah no now I even the cheap ones
that are 39 bucks like I have a little
bat Wheels car for my son and it works
way better than the super expensive RC
cars we' have to get Radio Shack so no
it doesn't make you a bad person makes
you a bad father should I should I Rebox
it or should I get another one maybe we
can have races here's what you do yeah
double up yeah double up here's what you
do you you um and by the way of course
this is a PG-13 so okay before I answer
first off first off this if you have
children watching today they probably
shouldn't be right this is p and if at
any point you see
this that means head on over to rumble
but what you should
ensure let's all be careful on how we
just is write a letter to Santa so that
Santa gives your son yes the RC car and
it doesn't have to be packaged where it
can have just a little you know tag that
says from Santa you know I I built this
personal batteries installed tires
slightly worn took it for a test drive
for you a couple of dents yeah so now
it's like a Santa car so it's it goes up
in value that's a genius idea that's
what I would do glad I asked but you're
a bad father
no I once made my sudden fall on his
face with one of those cars on accident
no that happens you put him on the car
and said let's see what it takes to make
him fall on his face Dad just wanted to
play with the car and I ran into him as
he was running and he didn't have
balance so all right before we move on
here this is something that happened
over the weekend there's some context
that needs to be provided there's
there's a UFC champion Sean Strickland
okay this guy is someone you probably
want to pay attention to he is probably
Autistic or as Asbergers he says
whatever is on his mind but he also is
you know would be considered an ally
he's certainly uh conservative uh he's
certainly genuine and he also was a
Loose Cannon and as profane as it gets
and he got into a fight uh with the
number one
[Music]
contender
first off of course you shouldn't be
brawling like you're going to fight rela
soon but I also enjoy the fact that the
fly weights were there Brandon Moreno
was there and the security guard
basically just like there's a reason for
hey you're the best flyweight which
means you're like the toughest guy at an
eighth grade slumber party so that's
still but let's in context his moves
him and uh I love that he tells the
child to move he says hey please get out
of the way get out of the way I'm about
to uh commit a
felony but
but Sean Strickland you know he's a
Loose Cannon and he made fun of this guy
implying that him and his coach were gay
because they do all kinds of weird
warm-ups things like that which I think
is fair play between Fighters flip side
is the other guy Mark dupi commented on
the fact that Sean Strickland has been
very open that he had an alcoholic
abusive father now Sean Strickland
should expect this when he talks as much
trash as he does but I'm sure that that
strikes a nerve and I do think that's a
little bit of a different level from
saying hey you and your you know you and
your coach playing touch butt in the
park or whatever it is so this is what
led to their fight is what happened at
the press conference the day before I
don't got to worry about finishing your
coach will finish you in the back like
you're used to don't worry about
that you think your dad beat the of you
you you your dad doesn't have on me
I'm going to show you what it's like to
beat you I all every childhood memory
you have is going to come back when I'm
in there with you every single one the
one where you li bed at night where your
dad comes in and he beats your out
of I will take your soul you
understand you
why does he laugh like Tucker
Carl it's a fake
laugh he's scared out of his mind what
if he left like Bill
Burr come on dude come on right your dad
used to beat you right not saying it's
right what are you shank son probably
messed you up for a while got to look
around make sure you're okay um what do
you think about that I so the trash talk
to me is is kind of fine I know what you
you think right we talked about this a
little bit before where you're talking
about his dad and beating him and yeah
yeah I can see that that's a problem but
at the same time he just said his his
gay coach was like you know fondling
coach isn't actually gay I know I'm just
saying he's insinuating it okay is he
just finishing him for funsies like yeah
I mean well he's not we're gonna get to
the senate in a
second
write here's the thing I don't I don't
have a problem with trash talk I get
like you are you are Fighters you are in
the fight business but look can I just
take a second then then he also talked
about Kobe Covington and I know a lot of
people out there are circulating Kobe
Covington because he showed up in a in a
George Washington outfit that he
purchased at Party City look I'm amazed
at some conservatives have been the man
is a fraud and this is the problem with
trash talk just for trash talk sake it's
the problem with social media it's why
I'm considering getting off of all of it
and just wiping the Slate clean on New
Year saying you want to know you want to
know what we I have to say tune in to
the show everyone is trying to so let me
present Kobe cumington he goes out he
hits a couple of buzzwords he says
Donald Trump made America great
inflation was better and our borders and
I fight for our troops and uh the
erection was the election was LE rigged
Le literally he misspeaks all the time
he goes and uh and so was this decision
go Donald Trump MAA and then here's a by
the way it doesn't work doesn't work he
can't sell the trash talk that actually
sold was someone who was being genuine
like a chill sunnon Conor McGregor on
the way up when he would say things that
were true you have Kobe Covington he
just said to a guy who seems like a
really nice guy oh you're a pedophile to
me that just seems that just seems like
you're going too and it doesn't work it
doesn't work we've created this culture
where everyone is trying to appeal and
there are so many people out there who
do this appeal appeal to the algorithm
and the crazy thing about the algorithm
these days this is the society that we
live in that keeps me up at night it's
not a real person used to be you were on
YouTube when people thought New Media
was great hey there are no more
Gatekeepers CNN ABC NBC CBS used to be
hey people subscribe to me on YouTube
they get to see what I create because
they want to watch what I am creating
hey people are following my Facebook
page they want to see what it is that I
create that's why they're following me
now it it doesn't even matter you
subscribe doesn't matter YouTube says
you want this you hit like doesn't
matter Facebook says you want this and
everyone is now trying to appeal to a
10c clip of an artificial brain it's not
even a human being It's Not a Human
Being it's it's a machine telling you
this works this doesn't work and people
are scrolling through saying not am I ve
do I do I have some kind of investment
in this person do I want to see this
comedian do I want to see this this
author it's am I entertained or pissed
off for 10 seconds I saw this weekend
one of these clip channels because it's
far more profitable to aggregate than it
is to create anything which is why we
have created mug club and hey if you
want to support us great if you don't
we'll go away it won't be around anymore
and enjoy the Instagram and Tik Tok
views I saw this the other day there was
a clip of Andrew Dice Clay saying one of
his nurt delivering one of his Nursery
rhy jokes yeah okay didn't attribute
Andrew Dice Clay just a joke and it all
the comments were oh hey this guy's
funny who is this or people saying this
is problematic and defend it's Andrew
Dice Clay yeah you're taking pride in
not knowing anything there's a problem
with the disconnect you may not like
Andrew Dice Clay you may think he's too
profane but it was his content that he
was ultimately creating for people who
wanted to consume that content say what
you want about Hollywood and it's all
right but those directors those actors
those producers they had to sell you a
product that they created we have now
disconnected the people people who are
assimilating content just assimilating
disseminating aggregating content who
have no connection to the content
whatsoever to feed this Beast that isn't
even a human being what is dictating
what you watch what you consume what
your children see it has nothing to do
with what they select to watch or see it
is an entire industry of people who will
Coach you who will charge you who you
can put on retainer to tell you how to
appeal to a person who doesn't even
exist now you combine that with the fact
that hey big Tech Facebook YouTube
Instagram Twitter up until recently you
think they have a vested interest in the
in the actual kind of content you want
to consume or you think they're going to
abuse that power once it's all been
Consolidated and I'm telling you it's
all being Consolidated to influence to
determine what it is that you're able to
view we've seen the White House call for
it and so you have dumb asses frauds
like Kobe Covington who don't sell
pay-per-views by the way say MAA Trump
great and some people go oh yeah okay
like they don't know who he is they
don't care they're not going to buy a
pay-per-view at a certain point when the
business is all aggregation and
assimilation there will be no content
creation so I don't and I don't want to
be a part I hate it I hate it I will
stand for everything that I say on this
show I will stand accountable not for
every single tweet taken out of context
or some clip that's you know what else
you see you know what else just really
rubs me the wrong you know you've seen
me do Stand Up You SE I'm pretty much
always the same person it's a PG-13
that's why we warn you you have these
Comics out there now who are r at Art
you can go and see them nc17 XX they'll
be humping a stool and then I see them
on their Instagram clips and to make
sure that they're not sensored they they
they blur bleep out the word sex and
spell it in the subtitles s e g gz oh
there you go Mr Rebel well I have to
make a living we don't if I'm saying
rape is wrong guess what you will not
see this on Instagram with the the word
rape bleeped out we used to fear the FCC
and a few guys in sweater vests which we
thought was going to be some kind of
Nanny State censorship and
instead we live in a society where
comedians have to edit out the word sex
regardless of content because you're not
being censored by the FCC but everybody
all of society to appeal to this Beast
to this artificial brain that doesn't
exist that determines what it is that
you watch what it is that you want does
everything start looking the same does
do you notice everything starts sounding
the same that's why I don't know if
there's any coming back from that I
don't where's it how is Thomas Soul
gonna get a get ahead in today how would
an Andrew Dice Clay oh he would never
how would a Louis CK never rush limbo
maybe not because someone because
someone said well you can't just do your
show you can't you got to go out there
you gota you got to do watch and reacts
where you just watch and you don't react
as we see from all of these think tanks
yeah can you imagine a young Rush yeah
2023 going into the the media Market I
just I hate it I hate it and if you know
if it makes me unhappy and I work in
this industry I guarantee what's making
you unhappy and so everyone that's the
problem with it the trash talk has to be
based on something real real something
real Floyd Mayweather okay you may not
like the guy but it was based on some oh
look Money Mayweather he's being cocky
so you hate him not just hey George
Washington I don't know anything about
the economy or politics let me throw out
a buzzword so that hopefully it gets
clipped and gets put up on Instagram
great you got 10sec views you got 5
million but your job fighting no one
wants to tune in and see it but your job
as a comic cool you slapped down a
Heckler great 10-second views no one
cares who you are they don't even know
who Andrew Dice Clay is yeah remember
when the fat Jew was a controversy
remember that guy cuz he was ripping off
comics and putting it in meme form yeah
that wouldn't be a controversy today
that's all it is that's all it is I just
saw memes that's a Louis CK joke so I'm
that's a j that's a Bill Bird joke that
that's an old Greg Geraldo joke and
someone takes credit for it and they
make millions of dollars with these
profiles without ever creating a thing
they have cancer of the funny bone and
the creative bone and these people
dictate what it is that everybody
consumes not to mention I'll be at the
Funny Bone but you
will at least creating content December
22nd 23rd you know what let me just
comment below if you want I just might
I'm not saying I'm going to get off of
social media but we might just want to
hit boom wipe the Slate delete
everything that existed and direct
people to where they can go and and see
some in in context we have lost
context in this society and that's why
everyone's that's why I don't want to go
and do some show where I'm in a quadrant
view for four minutes but I'll sit down
at at a black barber shop with eight
people where I could have just a hail
storm of black fists and feet if I say
the wrong thing I'm more comfortable
doing that than having something clipped
with a gotcha no one's trying to have a
conversation not to mention that that
content dilutes all of it whether be
comedy or whether it be fight press or
whatever that guy coming in acting like
that it totally dilutes all the real
good trash talking not the other one
trash talking and good banter back and
forth and a good drama good story right
that's fun that that other crap is just
you see guys who actually hate each
other yes or seriously though or how
many times do you see a comedian who's a
social media star it's like oh look they
they often set up right plant a Heckler
deal with it then people go and see the
ACT go oh there's no act yeah right that
happen what you do what what are you
doing how long you been together oh
Wisconsin that's gay oh
cheese wait there's an audience for hey
can we get that clipped and put it on
can we get coming right up make sure
anyway hit the comment thing there to
yeah you guys let us I we may just need
to hit a clean slate Gary don't have
Russian Gary don't have a heart attack
we'll still have something to do here
Gary's out there Sweating Bullets like I
just want to live and die by what what I
say that I believe here not by some that
someone Clips out of context and that's
the industry it is determined by hacks
and people who know how to tweak and
work social media and have never
actually created anything or met a fan
of their content that's a fundamental
shift in the landscape of how we consume
media and I think I think if you're to
if you're going to put a finer point on
what is wrong and why people are so
uninformed and why people are so
disconnected I think it's that big fake
computer brain called the algorithm that
everyone just wants to feed so they hope
they get killed last all right speaking
of feed I'm done speaking of
feeding
great in the
Senate
Aiden
mace
[Music]
chopski
a
[Music]
Harden has released a statement after
Ting one of his staffers due to their
alleged involvement in a sex tape the
sex tape was leaked on the social media
platform X the video allegedly shows the
staffer and another man having sex in
the heart Senate Office Building now
wouldn't mind seeing her Senate room
meeting tape yeah what do you want like
a DNA like confirmation he video taped
it and posted it it's not allegedly
having sex somebody was getting plowed
in that room okay there's no allegedly
about it secondly they were posing
before this I hear cuz I didn't watch it
somebody gave me that context wasn't me
what is this allegedly stuff and they
saw me in this it wasn't me I was in the
bench it wasn't me even did it in the
CIT who's going to bang all your interns
all
right I'd be asking for another chair if
I was that Senator
though worse than me putting on your
warm
headphones now and they're wet I heard
earlier last week this chovsky I hope
I'm pronouncing that correctly allegedly
approached uh a Jewish GOP
representative Max Miller of Ohio and
and and said to him free palisin now we
now know it was a euphemism for his
uncircumcised penis
but In fairness to the staffer who was
obviously a little Disturbed it's not
like there are many roofs left in
Palestine for him to be thrown off of so
you know it's a short here's a couple
you just tuck and roll a pillar or two
yeah now tropski said of both of these
incidents he said this has been a
difficult time for me as I have been
attacked for who I love to pursue a
political agenda agenda while some of my
actions in the past have shown poor
judgment like I would say uh
having gay anal sex in the Senate
Judiciary Committee hearing room and
filming
it want to say I love my job and would
never disrespect my workplace by having
anal sex in the Senate Judiciary
Committee hearing room and filming
it that makes sense to me I mean just
today I masturbated in the office just
so just I could respect the workplace
respect I wanted to respect you guys
it's a respect sign yeah you're welcome
it's the opposite of a power
move is that extra respectful to uh yes
it's extra respectful yeah it's extra
respectful not especially depending on
the refractory period you can you can
respect it
twice wasn't my office was it he
multiple respect you respect me out my
face why don't you boy this is just
that's what happened it's just the
gaslighting I would never disrespect you
sodomize a man in the Senate Jud and by
the way this has nothing to do with the
fact that you're gay remember it used to
be stay out of my bedroom you're not in
your bedroom you're in the Senate
Judiciary Committee hearing room this
has nothing to do with your bedroom no
one cares we care when you move it into
public office and you're shomiz somebody
while telling us that you would never
disrespect I love how the same write the
same defense by by who I choose to love
oh love is love sure love is love but
love is not always sodomy in the Senate
Judiciary Committee hearing room and
filming it what they do they make you
feel guilty as if you're some kind of
bigot or homophobe because you think
there something you shouldn't be having
sex in the Senate hearing room like oh
so let me guess if it was two straight
people you probably wouldn't yes we
would yes we would we absolutely would
want to see the tape but I would have
also condemned it yes depending on the
scale from 1 to 10 of the lady it's like
Anthony weer Bill Clinton they think
this just because of who I love no it's
because you're a degenerate
and you're allowed to roam the
halls of power freely yes yes the like a
predator well that's
true you
can is that is the speaker on no okay
that just has a good that just has a
good room tone all right so you guys can
comment below what's your favorite
example of a Democrat sodomizing
America hey even decency decency I'm
sorry deccy Americans have be that room
for
years it makes you feel any better my fa
screwed me too name that movie line what
and you can sign up at mug club by the
way all of this none of this exists all
of this is for you at led.com mugclub
you get this children's book no better
time to plug it than here uh beautiful
differences between now and the new year
once they're gone they're gone and um
hey we appreciate it none of this
happens without you and uh we have Nick
you have everything else there have Nick
depalo Alex Jones Brian call Mr gun your
Hodge twin so yeah we're trying to stop
feeding the Beast by feeding you okay
anything else no all right let's move on
VI had some Choice words for uh uh van
Jones who by the way no black people
know I spent a lot of time every time I
do black and white on the gray issues I
said van and they they have no idea who
he is which is why I've often said I
don't think that there's a single group
of people in the history of this country
who are more overly represented in media
without being represented at all Joy
Reed whoopy Goldberg van Jones does not
represent the average black American and
uh to prove that well we'll build our
case but we want to support the Flying V
Flying
[Applause]
[Music]
V this our tpusa event vake called
out well let me just be clear van Jones
we'll show the clip van Jones said that
VI was so disrespectful that he was
literally shaking is there anything not
to say that you're not black enough or
do that but is there anything less black
than a than shaking over like a fat joke
about Chris Christie yeah yeah it's just
to being soft yeah I just can't imagine
it so V uh called out van Jones for his
comments that he made regarding the
previous debate I say that on that last
debate stage to a bunch of Republicans
that are shaking in their boots these
are the things you're not supposed to
say in the Republican Party even today
and then you get the mainstream media
you got this character van Jones on CNN
afterwards saying this is the rise of an
American demagogue who's going to live
50 years longer than Trump this is
dangerous I am shaking that's what he
says just shut the f
up a certain point just shut the
up Van Jones at CNN see that's the
difference between phony trash talk and
just genuine disgust yes yes I think
think I I have a slightly different
opinion I think he went for an Elon Musk
moment while not being Elon Musk Elon
Musk did it a what a week ago two weeks
ago and then he comes out and says this
as a person who's running for president
I was just kind of like I feel like he
overstepped a little bit but I like the
sentiment you serious Clark but it also
shows you when you look at the tpusa
crowd you know where like people who are
you know writers for they're like
bloggers on uh some kind of a
publication that nobody reads and they
come stomping out with fireworks and and
a pyot Technics display like they're the
Heartbreak Kid it's like no one is there
for you and then they clip it and put it
up look at all the people who love me
like that just shows you how people are
starved for something at least semi
genuine like they reacted to that way
more than let me deliver red meat line
so I can plan my presidential run in
2034 or whenever the I don't know when
the election cycle is it's probably 2032
I have no idea the point remains I
appreciate it because people are going
can we stop having to sanitize
everything right and cut it for a clip
for a social media fake brain algorithm
by the way here's a clip from Van Jones
that V is referring to which I would
argue is the least black moment for a
media representative of all time and the
smug condescending way that he just
spewed this poison out is very very
dangerous because he won't stop Trump
but he's going to outlive Trump by about
50 years and you're watching the rise of
an American demagogue that is a very
very despicable person and I I'm I
literally I I was I was shaking
listening to him talking a lot of people
don't know that is one step away from
Nazi propaganda coming out of his mouth
oh what the Indian Nazi come on that was
yeah shaking we're taking the swasti
back yes he said it was a peace symbol
we had it first taking it back that's
not how he talks I feel bad cuz he talks
like he doesn't care he was on the show
he
laugh and you were like did I just do
that it's all fair
by the way let's and it wasn't just this
comment to be clear van Jones was mad at
all of the's Aura of being disrespectful
but this is something that particularly
bothered van Jones these comments where
he said the great replacement theory is
not some Grand right-wing conspiracy
theory but a basic statement of the
democratic party's platform that's what
he said now uh PolitiFact tried to claim
that the's comment was pants on fire
uh
who did my daughter write that yeah I
know that's P fact again it's all just
trying like Snow's fact check true fall
blit effects like we need to do better
pants on fire we rate this four
pinocchios liar and then you you
that there's no real journalism
anymore somebody wrote liar liar pants
on fire and an editor was like no cut
the liar liar we have no time pants on
fire simplify it brevity is the soul of
hack
journalism
so pants on fire because this is one
thing and I want to get to the point
about replacement Theory um it's not
it's not about race now some people may
use it in regards to race but um there
is more to it than that and I will tell
you the idea that westerners the idea
that people who love this country and
what it's meant to be are being replaced
proactively that's absolutely true you
can call that replacement Theory but
don't believe me believe your Ling eyes
and ears and let the Democrats tell you
for themselves it seems hard and harder
to ignore that The Echoes of replacement
Theory and other racially motivated
views are increasingly coming out into
the open in a few years we're going to
be a majority Brown country white people
will not be the majority in the country
anymore this will be the first
generation ever in American history uh
in which whites will be a minority of
the generation at some point as of 2007
every year babies being born in this
country whites now with a minority in
2044 uh everyone is going to be a
minority as the demographics change as
white people become the minority in the
country which is coming demographics is
Destiny demographics is Destiny
demographics is Destiny right the
country is changing I've been saying it
here other people been saying it here
for years now even before Donald Trump
the demographics is Destiny the white
population is declining for the first
time in history in America while the
number of multi-racial
Americans have more than doubled so we
live in a country where the demographics
are changing it's becoming less white
correct okay you'll be announcing that
we're calling the 38 electoral votes of
Texas for the Democratic nominee for
president it's changing it's going to
become a purple State and then a blue
State because of the demographics
because of the population growth the
growth in Texas has been almost entirely
driven by non-white population growth
mostly by Hispanic and Latino population
growth the idea that um you know whites
will will not be the
majority I mean that's it's an exciting
transformation of the country it's an
exciting Evolution and you know progress
of our country in many different ways
the white population is
declining it it was always on the
upswing so that speaks to the beautiful
diversity of America it speaks to um uh
how that population will the
demographics will weigh in politically I
believe anybody who e as a replacement
is to blame not for this particular
crime but it's it's for no purpose no
purpose except profit and or political
benefit and it's
wrong I believe that you and your son
are to blame for very particular crimes
yes very specific crimes that we can put
our finger on precisely yeah you know
and I want to go back to the point the
point that you just ranted on is why
they can get away with doing this to VI
because when he says great replacement
Theory or Grant the replacement Theory
or he says the January 6 was an inside
job and he tries to explain it but the
CNN lady continually Cuts him off for
minutes while he's trying to give you
the context behind what he's saying it's
because they don't want the context out
there because he's not saying what they
think he's saying the one step away from
Nazi propaganda he's saying something
that we're saying and like this is what
y'all have been telling us for years
Democrats well that's often for example
like something like Pierce Morgan was
known for doing that we would cut you
off try and frame you in with a very
specific question right and I may be on
his show here in the next next couple of
days hopefully he doesn't do that
hopefully it's a productive discussion I
usually don't like doing these shows
because I don't believe in them that's
why we do change my mind that's why we
do what we do here because I actually
enjoy and find some value in real
conversations but they're trying to cut
you off great oh so you mean racist you
mean racist you mean no you listen to
what they say they're talking about
replacing people who love this country
with people who want free things now
just to be clear I would rather have 10
migrants from Uganda who take the
Naturalization oath and want to start
businesses work hard and love what this
country is about I would have 10 of
those than one Swedish socialist but the
re the reality is we're not getting a
massive influx of Swedish socialists
we're getting a lot of people from South
America who are not fleeing oppressive
governments but they see a social safety
net of free stuff that the left dangles
like a carrot saying ah H you want free
stuff you have to vote for all the
depravity that comes with it that's the
replacement that is taking place and
it's exacerbated by the same leftists
who run your social media who run the
information of 90%
% of of what you
read that's what it is all right hit the
like button I guess if you're still
watching on YouTube I don't know why the
hell you are if you'd rather be
neighbors with an immigrant whose skin
color is different from you who's proud
to be American than a white leftist yeah
some of the mo and I don't know if
you've experienced this as well some of
the people that I've run into that are
the most proud to be here most thankful
for what we have are people who came
from somewhere else where it was
objectively worse right they are the
ones that know you have no idea what you
have sometimes right but not anymore no
I mean the people who came in the right
way people who came in the right way
their second generation or first
generation are like I came over from
Iran I came over from pick the place
that's not necessarily true today even
from those same places because a lot of
people today there's a huge difference
between for example the Irish the Jews
who came to America the Italians when it
was go go go go risk it hey go go tame
the wild west all right I'm willing to
CH I'm willing to bet on on myself for a
chance at Freedom that is a very
different
Dynamic than an incentive to immigrate
because of free stuff so when people say
hey give us you're tired you're hungry
the difference is you come here you can
maybe grow some food and eat you can
maybe fend for yourself everyone is on
equal footing now it's if you come here
for the free stuff but just make sure
you keep voting for it that's the
fundamental difference and that's why we
have to close the border and we have to
make sure that people sign the guest
book exactly yeah they wer coming
through Ellis Island and then getting
sent to a festar hotel right and getting
a electric scooter and a food card and a
right and a slave to they were coming
here and they were they were boxing John
Sullivan style in the streets to feed
their family they weren't picking up
their EBT card yeah and using it for
weed all right they
do I'm not even joking I'm not even
joking yeah hey how about this we spoke
with uh some people in the black and
white and gray issues there's a new one
coming up with two women an hour and a
half I said hey what do you think about
uh you know social safety the welfare
program they said a lot of people abuse
it you know white and black so they said
that and okay we didn't get into the
proportionality of it but I said how
about this would this be some common
ground um drug testing for someone who's
receiving welfare benefits I said yeah
they don't I said how about I understand
it people have had tough breaks right
unemployment insurance I understand all
of this social security but after a
certain amount of time if you're a
person who is able-bodied and can work
you work for one of the unskilled roles
in government and you get your check and
there's a job placement program they
said yeah they have job placement they
have that at least in prison I mean it
often doesn't work but at least they
have it I said great but right now you
go collect your check there's no drug
test and you don't ever have to prove
that you're going back to work some
people will say you do but let's be
honest you don't that's how you have
people on the welfare system for three
four five 6 seven eight years they
agreed with all of it they also agreed
with arming teachers who have concealed
carry they also agreed with school
choice go out and talk to people not
through a screen you'll be amazed as to
the common ground yeah the problem that
is happening this brings us to a macro
segment here that we really want to
touch on is uh the West is being if it's
being conquered it is being conquered
from within the the big threat is not
North Korea uh I wouldn't even say that
it's Iran it's us it's us it's and that
includes a lot of Western Europe to be
clear it's Western Civilization uh
undoing everything that we have done to
make this the place particularly the
United States the place where everyone
wants to come I don't know how long that
lasts so across the West uh culture
tradition history Pride you can't even
say that you can't even say history oh
that's racist you can't even say Pride
oh that must mean white pride no no no
pride in the ideas of this nation they
are being erased in real time you're
watching it and I want you to be aware
of this that it's not just when you see
a single story in a vacuum about a
monument this is happening AC across the
board every day all the time it's
happening in your schools it's happening
in your public buildings it's happening
in your public parks it's happening on
your social media
feeds everything that has made the
United States what it is that we've been
proud of for centuries is being erased
largely in the name of a progressive
Utopia using diversity as their primary
tool and the latest
victim to see how fast accelerates is uh
the national anthem in Canada recent
at a hockey
[Applause]
game I'm sorry wrong clip uh here is the
clip of the N of the multilingual
national anthem where they add 19
[Music]
syllables
22 new
syllables that guy doesn't even know
what they're saying nailed
it wait till they their Mongolian throat
singing version just sounds like
Dune so that was O Canada being
performed in Punjabi now let me be very
clear here I have to say it's one of the
many official languages in India because
in another uh example of where I think
uh Western Society should do it right uh
I say one of the languages in India
because there are 22 official languages
in India I didn't even know that was
there's Hindi there's Pabi there's
Bengali there's also so English so hey
if there's also English in India just
speak English there we
go support does you want to put a little
bit of little bit of spin on it or
Canada We Stand great great fine who
does this serve it doesn't even serve
the other 21 language speaking people of
India or the other Indian hockey players
on the ice yeah well let's be
what what they trying to a cricket match
they don't play
hockey I'm just saying I don't think so
at least well they're
there you can't have an official
language India has 22 hey how about you
know I think it's better to have one
maybe two tops okay we're going to start
we have to accommodate every other
country no no you don't have to do you
think in Brazil they're doing everything
in Hindi and punabi you think they're
doing that probably not doing it in
French and India I have no idea it's an
English colony seems like they're
they're using 22 languages they're just
saying all right toss another one in
here I have no idea but the point
is how is this it's not because they're
saying this is good this is a positive
this all stems from a negative it's a
negative thing that we're doing this in
English and French yeah that's we need
to be more inclusive we need to be more
inclusive otherwise we'll be in trouble
we'll be punished no it's not hey it
would be a positive thing to be more
inclusive because you don't need to be
inclusive to that degree otherwise you
have to sing it in every language and it
doesn't make sense you're a country you
have a language use that language and
the inclusive part is every single
person who also speaks Punjabi who's
there at the game can now take part in
your culture and hear the national
anthem in your language before you punch
each other's teeth
out didn't even sound good either
Stephen no it didn't I'd rather hear it
in American
language wait which which which note is
that there are too many words too many
syllables we changed the whole song yeah
I I want to know what they actually
said I don't care here's another sign
that the West is being erased from
within and again it's not based on a
positive affirmation it's based on
fearing punishment and retribution from
people and this is why I never want to
hear again from some small Fringe really
small Fringe I just heard this the other
day I think it was someone who was maybe
on Pierce Morgan maybe was on someone
else's podcast saying oh I'm so tired of
talking about the trans issue let's talk
about things that matter well hold on a
second it's people pushing back and
saying you can't allow men and women
sports because you pushed it don't
Gaslight people and saying why are you
talking about this because you changed
it if you say now we're going to sing
the national anthem in all of these
other languages by the way some of these
languages exclusively spoken in
countries that share nothing in common
with our values the push back the push
back is not keeping it relevant it's
that you didn't even allow a
conversation to take place
Fringe national anthem there changed
Fringe want to talk about abortion laws
in Virginia and California Fringe in
Minnesota they've now just released a
new concept for the state
flag the The Fringe is the entire
Democrat Party and the entire
Progressive left who run all of the
major platforms with the exception of
sometimes Twitter SLX and of course
Rumble which is more of a media site so
this is from Minnesota representative
Mike freeberg he's leading this flag
redesign and he called the current state
flag a cluttered genocidal mess how is
it a genocidal mess what what does it
has what does it have on there it looks
like the seal maybe of the state well no
it has a Native American riding horse
and I think it has a man like using a
hoe on the field or something like that
I don't know if he's black or white I
can't really tell from clearly they
literally placed the Native American
above the white man with the he's on a
horse which by the way you're welcome
Native Americans you hadn't domesticated
that until the white man came here
so now you get horses you had to take a
little bit of small pox but you know
what that's a fair trade baby steps they
were warm
blankets on horses on horses hey it
shows have you been to Minnesota
Minnesota lake minetonka think about
jingle all the way hey it's just two
blocks down on Wabasha everything in
Minnesota is Native American and it's
not done in a way to denigrate them
especially not on that flag Minnesota
but the idea is that it's large or at
one point was largely a white state so
to have a Native American as Majestic on
Horseback as he may be uh I have to say
that this is a genocidal mess before
someone comes down on me for not calling
out the clearly not racist flag none of
this is based on positive change it's
based on everyone trying to step through
a Minefield and avoid being punished it
sucks that's why that's how the country
dies when no one wakes up anymore and
says how do I actually make this place
better but they wake up and say o I have
Dodge that bullet which one's coming at
me today but so while we're talking
about this Native Americans as though I
haven't heard any Native Americans be
outraged certainly not enough of of a
percentage for the flag to be changed
one of the staunchest Defenders of
native
Rights was an insane person and the
governor of Minnesota commonly referred
to as the bod Jesse Ventura I think we
all need to take a look in the Mir Larry
and remember unless you're a native
American you're an immigrant and I think
we white people have lost sight of that
fact that we were immigrants too I
haven't because I marched in the protest
Sunday against the Washington nickname
for the NFL and it was a wonderful
protest we exercised our first amendment
rights there was no pepper spray no
chemicals used no
confrontations we got our point across
and it showed the greatness of America
Sunday in marching in Minnesota against
the Washington nickname of the NFL for
the show is called
politicking yeah look Larry King I was
their Wounded Knee tough
guy I wounded my knee in underwater
demolitions unit ah yes thanks
Washington Redskins know the facts
Redskins is a pejorative he wouldn't
even say the name it's a pejorative them
riding on Horseback they hadn't even
domesticated them yet I know that
because I have a place down a lake
motanka as well as a casa down in Mexico
where I make for stacos I'm
Multicultural
ass and even he didn't think that the
flag was a problem well but I here
here's the problem so they research
pointed this out to me this is a really
good catch he pointed out that the shirt
that he was wearing said Roosevelt high
Roosevelt I believe is quoted as
saying no the only good Indian is a dead
Indian he goes I don't necessarily
believe that but nine out of 10 probably
I think look you're trying to take it
out of context I don't think so he meant
to say dead tired from being far more
productive than the Immigrant white man
you ever seen Native American skin a
buffalo yeah you would you wouldn't be
able to move your arms after that
they're dead tired and they have a right
to be it's a majestic scene you're right
yeah thanks Chief real thanks for
serving your country oh really Chief you
going to say Chief to me Mr V wow all
right thanks nambi pambi Deputy yeah you
you did three foures I was underwater
with nothing but a bungee cord and a
reed debris through the top yeah what
happened to your hair though
okay yeah you're going to go add hominum
with that
look why don't you go put on some called
this is what happens when you do the
time warp again the hairpiece big dog
why don't you go join a real military
recruitment for I loved you and Broken
Arrow I like your beard hide your lack
of chin there tough
guy hey buddy I've got three chins all
right how many chins do you have I tell
you what you don't have you don't have a
lake house in cuz you couldn't cut it
there I love how his sweat was it was
the Redskins colors too it
was that's just because my sweater that
says College was in the
dryer so the new design proposed for the
racist Minnesota flag uh it's it's
similar to the flag of puntland puntland
pun punt linges do you know it's a state
in Somalia football really look at that
look go from so keep that up for a
second the old flag at the top like at
least it has some character to it right
fine if you want to make some
adjustments to it and it's not because
of this reason great but you go to that
new flag which just looks hideous it
looks like aqua fresh cool mint come on
yes oh yeah no you don't even know your
toothpaste that's actually the aim
Colors oh excuse me Jaz that's the aim
colors I used that for about two months
got canker Shores all the that's why you
lost half your teeth that's why you're
wearing Dentures
a I thought I was being Thrifty I was
slowly poisoning the
bod but here's the thing you say yeah it
doesn't have any Char well is this a
coincidence Minnesota now has the
largest Somali population in the United
States you can also hear the call to
prayer in areas I it used to be only ham
traic now you can hear it in areas
outside of the Twin Cities and uh by the
way there was a reporter on the scene
who had a tense moment when the
discussion of the flag came up
hey look at me sure look at me sure I'm
the captain now
they did they did make some progress
here's another one of the rejected
Flags yeah oh come on they
tried it's a disembodied floating head
keep in mind this is the state that has
a representative Anon Omar who married
her brother that's the marriage
certificate all references sources
available at louder withth credit.com
we'll put the link in the description
because some of you still don't believe
me we did a whole parody song about it
married her brother your brother
was that her brother on that Jolly Roger
flag well maybe the captain her
brother's the captain now it was a
standin look at you you you flipper
children belong to me
now I don't want look do you want to
live in a country where ilon Omar and
Rashida T get to claim that they
represent more Americans and then an
assat like Kevin McCarthy says the
Democrat Party at least represents
America more than our Republican country
does that repres presentent this country
absolutely not think about that for a
second this is look when we talk about
the replacement Theory or people talk
about identity it it has nothing to do
with race I should say it has very
little to do with race it doesn't have
nothing to do with race to be clear it
just so happens that a lot of people
coming to this country now tend to be
coming from South American countries or
Middle Eastern countries so sure they're
different than the majority of the
racial makeup here which is largely
white and they don't share the same
values but it brings you back to the
same place it is a lack of identity in
this country when it comes to values
just think about this for a second what
are the consequences sure we talk about
okay changing the flag right we active
sorry that's an active attempt to bring
more people in right hey look Somalia
come on right exactly there you go and
you know what I don't think that many
Somalians share our
values like hey hold on a second we're
talking about let's change the national
anthem let's do it in Punjabi let's
change our flag to look like a Somali
flag let's silence any let's tell people
to check their white privilege and and
that's the racial component but as far
as the identity the Constitution we need
to change it right you need to change
the Constitution by the way all of these
this is just a collage you'll have all
the references available in the link in
the description Constitution the leftist
tried to change it Declaration of
Independence okay they need to change it
the historical heroes of this country
erased them started with Jefferson
because God forbid the guy actually had
slaves I don't know is there slavery in
India how about
Somalia George Washington had slav of
course they freed them upon their death
that was the only way to do it back then
then we go to Teddy Roosevelt who
created the first national parks program
which you guys should be thrilled about
even went to Abraham Lincoln so it's not
enough in this country for Abraham
Lincoln who might have held slightly
racist views sure because he was a
product of that time but freed the
slaves but we want to bring people in
from countries where they still have
slavery it's not about right and wrong
it's about buying votes Bill of Rights
you got to change that we have some
identity in this country comes from our
constitution our bill of rights our
Declaration of Independence coffee
because we dumped a bunch of tea in the
harbor for crying out loud our flags we
have to
change now our flags they want to change
it there at least in that case they
might want to go through the legislative
process good luck but they're being
replaced and criminalized Wednesday
morning a group of Peace activists took
to the Golden Gate Bridge to protest the
war in Israel in support of Palestine Pi
aide cease fire not genocide protesters
chanted as workers gathered to remove
the Palestinian flag stop I don't want
to watch this
it's angry dude this whole and what
do you have in the United States 30% of
Americans ages 18 to 34 say that they
are not very proud or proud at all of
the flag sad okay now here's the thing
the left in trying to Pander and change
this country into something that it is
not for a very specific subset of a
generation of
people it doesn't work anyway they'll
never be proud of the country it doesn't
matter what you do they're prouder of
Palestine than the United States they're
prouder of places like Somalia than the
United States India than the United
States there are more slaves on Earth
than ever in recorded history just not
in the country that you're ashamed of
what what kind of results do we see well
the US military right now can't recruit
2023 saw recruiting shortfalls in the
army of 15,000 the Navy of 10,000 wow
give you some context 2023 125,000
people joined active
duty okay the year after 911 it was
181,000 22,000 people this year joined
the reserves right after 9911 it was
72,000 the US military is now at its
smallest since World War II this is a
quote from the military times lawmakers
say the reason for the lowest Target uh
the lower Target isn't a decrease in
missions or threats in recent years
instead the number reflects recruiting
challenges across the services and an
expectation of what level of personnel
is realistic in coming months well
considering what people see online again
through this giant Beast of an
artificial brain that we have to feed
constantly for 10c
views this is how the military is
portrayed there makes
[Music]
sense
it's just bad they allow makeup now in
the military apparently and Tik Tok they
did I think they did for a while yeah
shouldn't we get in trouble for that so
here's the issue that you also run into
right you see that in jenzy I love how
they're talking about in the Army you
get less sleep yeah that guy's a little
dude yeah well I don't want you in
the Army get the get out what are you in
in combat are you going to be like look
I swear if they give this food one more
time and by the way that guy he keeps
shooting at night and I can't sleep he's
not wrong by the way yeah the food sucks
the pay is not great you get a place to
live you get a gun what what happened to
service it's thank you for your service
not thank you for a cushy job with
handout thank you for your service and
the same should apply to politicians not
hey thank you for getting rich at the
taxpayer dime it's public service and
the problem is I would wager now they
don't want to get these they don't want
these numbers to be out there so if
someone has them please send them to us
it's very difficult to find the people
that they are catering to gen Z
Millennial lgbtq a i plus are not
joining right so the people like you see
these advertisements from the military
the one with two moms right they need
stretchy maternity suits for women in
their third trimester paid gender
reassignment surgery so they're saying
come one come all lgbtq AI uh P plus
number two whatever the hell it is in a
silent silent hashtag come in we need
you in the military they're not coming
in anyway because they might have God
forbid a lack of sleep but the guys who
used to join the military MH the the
young men who wanted a license
[Music]
to flight suit and lose promotions to
them by the way and lose promotions to
them or do you think he wants a brother
so those people aren't joining because
you're catering to people who don't like
this country and aren't going to join
anyway luckily the Army has a foolproof
plan to change people's
minds and you know what I appreciate
that they RI me off I don't care but you
got the font wrong you did yeah and
that's not very creative well their
budget was low and bad
food they they they got to put their
makeup on and stuff they're advertising
the wrong people it's like a it's like a
candy machine in a diabetes Ward right
yes thanks Mars Bar Bar appreciate my
kid's
dying sorry two bar it's like selling
time shares at a Ronald McDonald
House future someday you're going to
really use it what am I going to do with
this just sign on the dotted line right
here it's legally binding we're a good
charity and it if it just existed in a
vacuum it would still be bad but then
when you apply this on a global scale
places like China at the same time
nationalism and I'm not saying this is a
good thing they take it to the other
extreme being taught from an early
[Music]
age yes that was a Chinese
kindergartener shooting Japanese
imperialists oh my God was it a
reenactment of hist
no Thursday kind of yeah you know what's
funny is like there's a middle ground
right there's a middle ground between
being way too soft and way too hard yeah
and I when I was in when I was overseas
we'd get letters from kids sometimes and
gosh they were so funny dude I wish IID
saved a bunch of them because they'd
have like pictures like kids were like
drawing blood and like just 10ad people
like have fun good luck at the war
whatever and I'm like what are kids what
are kids writing now I don't know I hope
you get your stretchy maternity suit
don't forget your Thanksgiving pants
you're you're killing every like we used
to watch movies and see American kind of
greatness just portrayed in movies just
naturally right they weren't pandering
to us it was just like yeah and you're
like hey I'm proud of my country Air
Force movies fantastic Jets the United
States leading the way great now it's a
surprise when we see that with top gun
Maverick everybody's like oh thank God
we finally had a movie that didn't take
a steaming dump on America and it
actually performed incredibly well like
there's a huge group of people that just
want to be proud of their country and
they have plenty of reason to be proud
of their country but the media tells
them they don't right lot of antagonists
too antagonists that are like military
characters like a colonel or an admiral
like a hard ass that just ruins all the
fun and no one likes him com like when
you need him yeah you know well he died
I understand that rest his soul another
in I meant like part no I know I know
but you know what it was just for you
uh so here to set us straight because I
know that have a blind spot we're
willing to have people uh on the show
who likely uh disagree with us is the
first ever female fourstar Admiral fstar
Admiral definitely rear Admiral Rachel
LaVine to give us some
[Music]
insight all right Admiral LaVine thanks
for taking the time not a problem stepen
happy to be here yeah okay so uh we see
that we are having an issue right now
with recruitment in this country do you
care to comment uh yeah we've recruited
some fine strapping young people
couldn't be more proud well okay sure
but you you've Fallen significantly
short of the quota worst it's been since
World War II oh that was World War II
was something wasn't it all those
strapping Sailors and their strapping
sailor costumes I think well I think you
mean their their uniforms yes that's it
God bless
seean I saw the Army is is changing its
focus uh or at least the demographics
for recruiting now I because I we
understand we were just talking about
this they want to focus more on on
graduates and less on high school
students well I'm not allowed within 30
yards of most high schools Stephen yeah
that does check out that was going to be
my follow-up question I'd like to check
you out um no okay I'd like to
transition here to uh been there done
that I'm not going to get a straight
answer out of you at all LaVine am I the
fabulous
I don't even know what
[Music]
this so let's just that's in conclusion
before we go to mug club and play
Photoshop or not uh movie poster
Edition that was a pretty mouth yeah a
prettiest thing on her did you hear
those
banjos so those ad Ravine look
like the progressive left they are
actively attempting to erase the identi
of this country they do so by erasing
Flags historical monuments wanting to
change the Constitution our Bill of
Rights and then they appeal to
immigrants uh who have no desire to be
American whatsoever while browbeating
you for being proud of your American
Heritage and then of course condemning
you if you talk about the replacement
Theory which they have actively admitted
uh as racist so everything that they say
when you repeat and say I believe that
that's a problem they say no no that's
racist well I'm just repeating you and
now we have the mil
actively promoting the recruitment of
people who have no interest in joining
while shunning the people who were
looking to defend the country they were
once proud of anyway and all of this all
of this alienates the
people let me put a finer point on it
here's the
difference we're committing National
Suicide okay and I asked you earlier in
the show in case you're you've tuned in
later do you think that you are fighting
to preserve the United States of America
now or do you think that now you're
really just keeping an eye out for who's
going to help rebuild comment
below there certainly is an attempt to
commit National
Suicide Michelle Obama to give you an AB
comparison Michelle Obama when her
husband became
president I use the term loosely when
her husband became president she said
for the first time I actually felt proud
of my country
that's the left I will tell you this for
the first time in my lifetime I would
say the last year two years really
postco and the rapid expansion of
lgbtq
AIP and and and and racial Theory Black
Liberation
theology for the first time in my adult
life
uh I don't know that I'm proud of what
we've become
I was she had never been proud to be
American and she only became proud to be
an American when her husband became
president I have always been proud to be
American and loved this country but for
the first time I worry if we look back
on the historical record for the first
time in my life might say hey in a lot
of instances
there we were wrong and maybe we were
the bad
guy I think that's the flip and it's not
an external Force it's an internal one
stop feeding the monster and talk with
people I cannot stress this to you
enough the monster the screens the
algorithm when that's all there's a huge
difference between the society that we
lived in where you tuned into Carson and
you shut it off and the next morning you
got up you ate your breakfast you went
to school you went to work you spoke
with people you went out you were a part
of some social clubs or sporting
activities part of society and then
maybe you watched a couple of shows
Charlie Rose maybe Carson maybe
Letterman went back that's not the same
as you get up you look at a screen where
you are being indoctrinated when you're
at your school your job you're largely
looking at a screen and if you're not
you're thinking about looking at that
screen and when you get home you are
looking at that screen it's the first
thing many people see when they wake up
in the morning it's the last thing they
see when they go to bed and it's the
number one thing that is always on their
mind and that is a portal to a
monster that has no Humanity by
design get off of
it use it as a tool but stop feeding
it I know it's not a popular thing to
say and I know that people that's why
hey we make the references available I I
believe in Reading articles can you C
can we all get back to that not just 10
seconds in a
snippet we went from long form to
Shorter form to several second form we
went from newspapers and I get it they
were always by we went from books
stories by the campfire to
newspapers to reading blogs and online
articles to just headlines to now just
captions that again have to feed this
godforsaken and I don't use that in vain
godforsaken algorithm because there is
nothing holy there it is a soul sucking
monster and it tells you that there's
nothing to be proud in this country well
you know what if you look around maybe
not today there's a lot to be proud of
if you get off those social media
ghettos for a second do a little bit of
research this whole planet this whole
globe was fundamentally Changed by one
country that left the world's greatest
superpower one century to become the
only world superpower of The Next
Century it's never been done before or
since not even close and what made it
great was not 10c views on Tik Tok all
right we're going to mug Club where
we'll talk about this a little more chat
Photoshop or not we thank you very much
Rumble I apologize for the I guess the
kids call it spicy these days I'm
pissed thank you Rumble YouTube go
fornicate yourself or
[Applause]
urinate
[Music]
a